When you think of electricity, what's the
first thing that comes to mind?
Probably a wire. We're used to thinking of
metals as the best way to conduct
electric current.
And it's true--metals are found in pretty
much all the electronics that we use:
in light bulbs, phones, computers, TVs,
and countless other appliances. But believe it or not, there are certain non-metals,
such as conductive plastics that can act
as conductors, too.
Their special properties challenges our
assumptions about non-metals,
and allow them to harness the power of
electricity. Although electricity can
seem like magic,
the science behind it is pretty simple. An electric current is just the flow of
electrons from
atom-to-atom. Different atoms are better
at connecting electrons than others
which is why materials like metals are
generally more conductive than others.
This is because the electrons metals are
delocalized,
meaning that the outermost electrons in
a metal atom are held loosely,
allowing them to flow more freely. In
contrast,
the outer electrons in the atoms of a non-
metal are held more closely to the
nucleus,
preventing movement. Think about an
electrical wire.
Inside, the charges flow easily through the metal filaments.
On the outside, the rubber coating keeps
these charges from flowing into our
bodies
and electrocuting us when we touch the
wire. But electrically-conductive plastics
turn this idea on its head.
These plastics are polymers, long
chains made of smaller,
repeating units known as monomers. By
changing the structure of
the atoms within the monomers, these
plastics can actually become
just as conductive as certain metals. Sounds pretty cool,
right? You may think that some brilliant
chemist made these plastic specifically
for this purpose.
But, like so many other important
discoveries in science,
this one was an accident. It happened in the Lab of Hideki Shirakawa,
when the chemical compound polyacetylene
was mixed incorrectly.
Normally black and powdery, the compound
instead formed a silvery
film that looked distinctly metallic. Wondering if this strange substance would
exhibit metallic properties,
Shirakawa shared the discovery with chemist
Alan MacDiarmid
and physicist Alan Heeger. After
experimenting with many different
processes,
they discovered that they could actually
increase the conductivity
of polyactylene to rival that of certain
metals. With the addition of bromine gas,
for instance,
the conductivity of polyacetylene
increased 10 million--fold--
to a level that approached that copper. Although a different conductive polymer,
polyaniline, had existed for almost two
centuries,
the accidental discovery of polyacetylene
brought the field of conductive polymers
to the forefront and opened up a
revolutionary new possibilities for
experimentation.
While metals are generally the best
conductors we have available today,
there are many downsides to their use. Mining,
shipping, and processing metals is
expensive. Conductive polymers
are attractive alternatives because
they are lightweight, cheap
and functionally versatile. So how do these conductive polymers work?
Like in metals, the flow of electric
charge in conducting polymers is
generated by voltage--
a difference in the electrical potential
the negative and positive poles of a
battery
or an outlet. The negatively charged
electrons are drawn towards the positive
pole,
and they create a current as they pass from atom-to-atom. But like we mentioned,
the electron of polymers usually aren't
delocalized, and cannot easily move around
to conduct current.
But let's take another look at polyacetylene.
if you look closely, you'll notice that
there's an alternating pattern of single
and double bonds holding the atoms of the polymer together.
This is known as a conjugated backbone. Along this backbone,
the sigma bonds hold each atom together by
concentrating electrons directly between them.
The pi bonds, which constitute the
second bond in each double bond,
strengthen the connection between their
atoms by attracting electrons above and
below the plane and the molecule.
This forms delocalized orbitals,
where the mobility of electrons can be
enhanced
through a process called "doping." This process
essentially changes the number of
electrons in the polymer,
by either removing or adding electrons to the
atoms. Removing electrons
create empty spaces in the outermost
orbital the atom,
allowing the remaining electrons to
move around more freely.
Adding electrons forces an atom to
create another orbital--
and so long as this orbital isn't full, the electrons have more space to
move around
and hop from atom-to-atom. You can think of it
like a pool table full of billiard balls.
The balls would be able to move around, if they weren't getting in each other's way.
But if you take out a few balls, the
rest of them can move
around. Or alternately, if you add more
balls,
you need to add a new pool table. In this new pool
table,
they have lots of room to move around. The more easily they can move around,
the more easily they can transport
charges and conduct electrical currents.
Although initially no one believed that
polymers could conduct electricity,
the scientific community has since cut
up to Shirakawa's research.
In 2000, Shirakawa, MacDiarmid
and Heeger were awarded the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry--
and the research around conductive
polymers has grow exponentially
While the full potential of conductive
polymers has yet to be discovered,
there are countless possibilities for
developments in technology and medical since,
such as high-capacity batteries, artificial
muscles, and biosensors.
So while we probably won't see plastics
entirely replacing metals in our
lifetime,
the field of conductive polymers has huge
potential,
especially for something that began as a
mistake.